from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
it was the speech that changed
everything
no prime minister wants to enact
measures
like this i know the damage that this
disruption is doing
and will do to people's lives to their
businesses
and to their jobs one year ago the
country
commanded into lockdown it brought panic
eerie emptiness and deep personal grief
he had a great sense of fun it had a
great sense of humor
he loved to sing songs and um yeah real
memories of him singing to them
it was lovely rachel pennant's dad cliff
died last april he was in a care home
and caught covered i used to watch the
news in the evening
and i would see the numbers going up and
i would always think i would take one
off
and think that one was my dad
it has been an unimaginable year for us
all
care homes and hospitals found
themselves in need
with shortages of ppe three of these
words
no all homes became schools and offices
you have no authority here jackie weaver
no authority
at all as we all got to grips with
remote working
and although distance from each other
communities
felt closer
[Applause]
but constant reminders too no one was
immune
from covid not even the prime minister
126 000 people have lost their lives
the numbers are still rising
but so is hope
the last year will affect us all for
years to come
the impacts of cover 19 are going to
play out
over a much longer period and this is
because things like the social
the economic and the cultural impacts
will uh will play out and cast a long
shadow
into the coming decade as we look back
on the last year a minute silence at
midday
and candles on doorsteps whatever our
faith
or philosophy may be let us take a
moment
together to remember those who have been
lost
to give thanks for their lives and to
acknowledge the inexpressible pain
of partying it's a pain still being felt
by many what i'll be doing is i'll be
looking back
um but i'll be trying to remember some
of the hopeful things of the past year
as well
because um i i think we're all looking
forward to moving on
i will be remembering but i will be
remembering
with hope too laura bundock
sky news hodgeston in hertfordshire